[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis
sanierers welt heute backen wir bürger
bands ich habe schon ein richtig gutes
bürgerbahn rezept auf einem kanal
die formen sind einfach frei aus der
hand und sie werden wirklich perfekt
aber dann kam was dazwischen denn nach
diesem bürger bayerns haben wir kebab
kennen gelernt in karlsruhe unser
lieblings dönerladen und ich muss dazu
sagen dass der übergabe der macht schon
die besseren brötchen aber muss das sein
das ist toll aber dann hatte ich sie
diese vision dieses brot dieses
fluchtwege weiche brot als burger
umzufunktionieren deswegen machen wir
heute burger bands und ich habe mir ein
paar tricks und tipps und tricks beim
abgeholt also wer aus karlsruhe kommt
aus der umgebung oder irgendwann mal
geschäftlich oder privat in karlsruhe
ist bitte probiert kabi dollar aus es
kann sein dass sie draußen bisschen
warten müssen weil immer eine
warteschlange ist aber es ist wirklich
der beste dünger und es gibt ihn auch
vegan also probiert es einfach aus vegan
vegetarisch war gibt's alles und alle
sind sehr helfen
jetzt probieren wir es aus der frau
wären die kabi brote in mega fluffig und
luftig dafür braucht ihr allerdings
kleine edelstahl ringe also kleine
tortenring sozusagen burger ringe
denn darin werden sie gebacken und der
hefeteig ist auch eine sehr flüssige
weicher hefeteig
dafür nehme ich einen wirklich 300 gramm
warmes wasser 30 zucker und 30 vom
zucker sirup 300 gramm joghurt das ist
der drei hundertprozentige drei eier 900
gramm mehl
ich nehme ein 550 e mail zwei esslöffel
salz und 100 kommen sondern zuerst gibt
jetzt einfach die hefe in die röhre
schüssel
ihr könnt den teig auch mit der hand
verkneten visa mir schon sagte aber was
sollte schon zehn minuten kneten von
daher wasser dazu
und jetzt muss die jäger auf aufgelöst
werden
darfst auch durch gleich mal jetzt schon
hier zuckerrübensirup noch mit rein und
dann kurz berühren von miramax video
leben
den recht könntest du an den rat jetzt
bis zum schluss typisch schwäbisches
mittel das merke ich schon
bitteschön
[Musik]
jetzt ist alles am finger jetzt ist ganz
wichtig nicht direkt salz oder fett
geben sondern wirkt sich erstmal das
mehl damit die hefe nicht durch salz
oder fett beeinträchtigt wird sozusagen
und jetzt könnt ihr aber wirklich alle
zutaten dazugeben
den teig kneten für etwa zehn minuten
wenn ihr auch die cooking chef habt ihr
keinen mit küchenchef dann gerne auch
direkt mit ihrer sitzung zu 34 grad
da wird die hefe schon mal schön warm
quatschkopf
[Musik]
effekte daraus guck mal
und es ist wirklich ein schöner
flüssiger teig der auch schön klebrig
ist und so muss es sein denn ich möchte
später einen richtig lockeren luftigen
burger bahn haben
ich nehme jetzt hier einfach den
knethaken raus deckt den teig ab und ihr
könnt ihn entweder an einem warmen ort
offen zum beispiel oder auch in der
maschine oder bei der stufe bei 34 grad
aufgehen lassen aber abgedeckt natürlich
hier oder eben bei raumtemperaturen und
es kann nicht sein dass es eine stunde
geht oder zwei kann auch eine halbe
stunde dauern
achtet einfach drauf dass er wirklich
bis mindestens aufs doppelte aufgeht
[Musik]
der hefeteig ist wunderbar aufgegangen
also der weiß wirklich tatsächlich bis
hoch in die schüssel und bis hoch in die
maschine kommt ich zeige euch das mal
denn ich habe mich aufgepasst also ich
habe wirklich so nach einer stunde schon
mal den teig runter gedrückt und dann
ging er noch mal sofort hoch und er ist
mir bis in die maschine reingewachsen
jetzt mach dir folgendes wirklich
einfach alle elemente wegnehmen
den teig trocknen lassen denn wenn ihr
jetzt mit einem tuch daran geht für
mediales also das jetzt einfach alles
trocknen und wenn es trocken ist es
einfach weg ist und entweder mit einem
tuch oder schwamm oder mit einer bürste
und dann bekommt ihr alles wieder sauber
denn ich denke das kann schnell auch mal
jedem passieren
deswegen habe ich diese weggedreht das
ist nicht so gut warum werden diese
bürgerbahn fluffig und heute erlaube ich
mir wirklich ganz auf das wort fluffig
zu erwähnen denn datei gesetzt ganz
flüssig und wird jetzt praktisch in
diese ringe ein gefühltes hin so
barbecue bürger bringe aber im prinzip
kann man damit auch wunderbar kleine
törtchen backen und die sind vom
durchmesser erwarte ich sag's euch
durchmesser 10 5 cm
also ich finde es auch eine perfekte
burger bands größe und so kenne ich die
hat auch vom ghb also die sind da dieses
brot dort dass ich einfach der wahnsinn
und es gibt viele menschen die einfach
nur wegen dem brot hinfahren oder die
holen sich darin döner stellen sich an
und kaufen dann aber so zehn brote zum
einfrieren die sind wirklich also
vorgabe ihr macht echt die besten brote
muss ich wirklich wirklich sagen ich
hoffe meine werden nicht genauso gut ich
habe es noch nicht ausprobiert aber wir
werden sehen ich habe mir kurz überlegt
die förmchen zu fetten aber dann dachte
ich mir nein bei bis mittag und für tag
fertig sei auch nicht meine tortenring
damit der teig praktisch am rand
hochklettern kann und nicht immer wieder
so zusammenfällt
ich probiere es jetzt einfach und wir
werden sehen und ich denke hier passen
ich glaube ich mache
wo ist ein und findet gleich noch ich
denke ich für sie jetzt wirklich auch
nur bis zur hälfte damit der teig noch
mal zeit zum aufhören
ich möchte das jetzt hier ab das heißt
jetzt die schüssel mit dem teig auf
einer waage habe die auf null gesetzt
und schiff jetzt praktisch raus und es
geht dann ins minus und dann weiß ich
einfach später auch ganz genau dass ich
eben alles richtig ich denke ich werde
ich habe jetzt hier
150 gramm ich bleibe mal weiter nichts
auch richtig schön luftig und locker
werden
ich könnte auch zweitens aber nehmen
müsste ich euren finger neben aber ganz
ehrlich was macht das spaß
[Musik]
applaus für samira das perfekte klappen
mädchen
danke dafür später wisst ihr es ist
einfach und ich habe freunde den tag x
so pi mal daumen mir so einfach
theoretisch zusammengesucht und dann
gucke ich habe zwölf ringe und dann habe
ich seit 450 gramm kokain und wenn dann
der teig einfach so exakt aufgeht ist
das schon
eigentlich sollte es nicht noch ein
wunder es ist augenmaß oder es war
einfach intuition
es sind 303 also das heißt 150 950 die
schüssel ist leer
es gibt genau auf zwölf stück wahrheit
oder lüge kann das sein
ist es das ist das was sie sehen nur
eine illusion
oder ist diese geschichte wie sie dieser
frau in waghäusel widerfahren ist
wirklichkeit
entscheiden sie selbst
eigentlich wäre der perfekte job
ja weil du sara wie schon so die
journalistin bei uns im hause wir
erinnern uns zurück an sarah die
journalistin
breaking news aus waghäusel wir haben 12
35 und bei sally ging der rauchmelder an
wir sind natürlich live vor ort und
können der besagten sally ein paar
fragen stellen sally wie kam es dazu was
ist passiert
es ging im prinzip damit los habe den
ofen auf zehn minuten eingestellt da
sagen die kekse noch perfekt aber es war
noch nicht durch und ich hatte damals
fünf minuten acht gestellt und jetzt ist
einfach
das einzige was ich jetzt noch tun werde
ich möchte natürlich die oberfläche
glätten und es geht natürlich etwas
schwierig mit seinem weichen teig
das heißt ich hätte meine hände mit back
trend spray er könnte aber auch wasser
und ich hoffe dass die oberfläche jetzt
dadurch glatt genug wird das wäre etwas
schade wenn sie nichts passiert und sie
sehen jetzt übrigens ungleichmäßig
gefüllt aus weil einfach der teig schon
wieder aufgegangen ist während ich hier
noch man muss schon fast so viel vor
schmerzen hand eine hand maske machen
sprich die oberfläche und glatter sie
sehen ich hoffe
aber ich sehe schon unter trägt er
klettert jetzt schön am rand hoch also
ich glaube dies könnt das könnten
[Musik]
jetzt sind die brote erst mal soweit und
jetzt ist das geheimnis lasst sie
wirklich schön lange ruhen bis ich die
form wieder füllt ich muss jetzt einfach
selber mal gucken ob es eine halbe
stunde reicht oder stunde
ich hoffe ich hab's nicht zu voll
gemacht sodass du praktisch nicht gleich
auslaufen
aber da aber terror vorgabe hat gesagt
man muss dir lange aufgehen lassen und
ich denke das sollte ich jetzt auch tun
und ich hoffe dass die 150 km nicht zu
viel waren falls doch mach es nochmal
und hülse mit 100 gramm haben wir
probieren es aus und ich stelle jetzt
einfach im backofen
ich glaube die gerbstoffe mache ich
jetzt gar nicht sondern ich lass dir
wirklich so aufgehen dass sie für euch
dann auch die perfekte derzeit praktisch
bestimmen kann und dann gucken wir
gleich sagt okay
ich hoffe dass ich noch die brote sind
jetzt runter war aufgegangen ihr herz
schon immer ist auch mit dabei
eigentlich waren sie gerade eigentlich
waren sie gerade perfekt aufgegangen
aber ich muss schneller abholen im
kindergarten und deswegen sind die jetzt
tatsächlich zu lange aufgegangen ist
wenn sie so sind so gerade an davon sind
sie perfekt ich habe es hier aber
einfach so gemacht jetzt auch finde ich
gar nicht so schlimm also zum einen sich
auseinanderleben das hat mich freuen
soll und zum anderen und vielleicht
nicht dass sie beim backen überlaufen
ich mache ich einfach so und wir
probieren es jetzt einfach probieren
ganz vorsichtig zurück und wir gucken
einfach wie sie gleich fertig gebacken
aussehen ich helfe dir sofort shops und
du hast einen eigenen mit zwei esslöffel
milch ein bisschen mehr und ein mit vier
esslöffel mensch hat samira grad
verkehrt
ja du darfst gleich helfen muss aber
erst mal deine hände waschen
[Musik]
jetzt ganz vorsichtig weil wir wollen
jetzt das brot nicht zu drücken
wirklich so leicht eigentlich mit einer
sprühflasche die blasen was ich mache
das eine gleich mal fertig dann von dort
tauschen dann seid ihr weiter geschäft
nicht der weg hier du darfst oder wohl
die beide streuen melaka nicht streichen
das ist eine aufgabe für große mails
verleiht ganz wenig nehmen und soja so
unser mehr macht dann saison also sesam
und schwarz grünen haben es hier
[Musik]
ihr macht das super schönes bisschen
blau und schwarz kann mir ist so schwarz
ich bin jetzt echt so richtig richtig
gespannt wie das klappt und wie das dann
gleich aussieht und und jetzt müssen sie
direkt in den vorgeheizten backofen
gleich heiß gebacken werden und wir
drücken einfach die daumen dass es
klappt ich glaube ich mache jetzt
einfach weiter buy
marokko
[Musik]
das haben wir doch mal wie sehen die
klitschkos bitte schoko das ist schon
gut geworden mit decken sich ab und
lassen sie ruhe lesen sie später aus dem
ring und daraus machen oder kohle bürger
aber mit in diesem video
aber in diesem video zeige ich euch hier
sehen aussehen
[Musik]
als muss echt sagen ich hab dir nochmal
gemacht und dann wirklich nicht so lange
aufgehen lassen sodass eben nicht über
diesen ring schauen und dann direkt
gebacken und die sind wirklich perfekt
als 150 gramm ideal
ich habe auch gerade noch schaut mal ein
blech gemacht mit 100 gramm reis sind
auch gut also die sind nicht ganz so
hoch aber ich bin fan von diesen 150
gramm berger ich hatte nur vorhin die
wahl zwischen bug ich jetzt die bürger
und die werden perfekt oder obwohl ich
mein kind vom kindergarten ab also habe
ich doch die elan immer vom kindergarten
abgeholt
aber wie gesagt 150 gramm perfekte
bürgerfonds ich bin ein fan und jetzt
habe ich sie einfach kurz abkühlen
lassen wird war zehn und zwanzig minuten
1000 kommt ein sturm auf egal
und dann kann man sie auch ideal mit so
einer palette herauslösen und dann auf
einem kuchengitter abkühlen lassen
schön richtig schön
[Musik]
also hier sind die fertigen burger
brötchen ich habe es jetzt einfach
herausgelöst und hab gedacht mit und tue
damit so schön abkühlen jetzt probieren
wir sie einfach aber aussehen trug schon
irgendwie cool aber ich könnte mir gut
vorstellen das amberger ziemlich cool
aussieht also dann aufschneiden und wenn
ich jetzt den burger belege würde sie
natürlich erst aber noch an grillen und
du willst du oben oder unten probieren
und so ein stück abreißen
das sage guck mal komme ich probiere mal
von oben wenn wir wollten jahr habt also
die sind schon als zum einen kreis
saftig richtig saftig ganzen weich und
flüssig
[Musik]
richtig richtig lecker also wir werden
daraus einen burger zaubern
wie wärs mit dem sommer burger
saarburger das machen wir wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie wir diesen sommer
bürger machen dann schaltet einfach das
nicht immer allein
da machen wir den burger und jetzt habe
ich ein grundrezept für leckere burger
bands aus dem burger ring also viel spaß
bewahren viel spaß beim nachmachen und
bis zum nächsten mal vielleicht können
wir noch in wega machen und habe einen
veganen burger wenn ja dann schreibt in
die kommentare
[Musik]
nicht schlecht und man kann sie sogar
einfrieren einfrieren auftauen aufbacken
perfekt
[Musik]